le journal de l'afrique sur france24
soyez les bienvenus à la une ce soir les
graves accusations du mahdi à l'encontre
de la france bamako à puce paris de
soutenir les djihadistes et de violer
son espace aérien des accusations
portées devant les nations unies alors
que la force marque anne a achevé son
retrait du pays en début de semaine nous
serons à new york dans ce journal ces
nouveaux heurts en guinée une dizaine de
jeunes se sont affrontés à la police et
aux gendarmes dans la banlieue de
conakry des heures suite à un appel à
manifester les manifestations ont été
interdites par les militaires au pouvoir
depuis le mois de mai et puis à la fin
de ce journal on vous parlera du
phénomène des chiens errants au maroc le
royaume a décidé de faire face à ce
fléau le roi a interdit l'abattage des
animaux mais d'autres solutions sont
envisagées
reportage à suivre
[Musique]
la lettre adressée à l'onu par le mali
est datée du 15 août elle est signée de
la main du ministre des affaires
étrangères doulaye diop lee porte de
graves accusations à l'encontre de la
france violation de l'espace aérien et
soutien aux terroristes des accusations
qui interviennent alors que la force
marc khanne achevé son retrait du pays
en début de semaine notre correspondante
à new york fanny et chauvin revient sur
cette lettre envoyée au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu
selon les autorités maliennes la france
fournirait des armes et des munitions
aux groupes djihadistes du sel mais pas
seulement la france est accusée
d'espionnage
d'après bamako elle fournirait à ces
renseignements à ces mêmes groupes
terroristes ces informations la france
les obtiendrait par des violations
fréquentes et répétitives de l'espace
aérien malien par des hélicoptères des
avions de chasse ou encore des drones
des survols sans autorisation selon
bamako qui aurait enregistré une
cinquantaine de cas depuis le début de
l'année dans sa lettre le ministre
malien des affaires étrangères menace
même la france de représailles le malige
site se réserve le droit de faire usage
de la légitime défense
si les agissements français persiste
conformément à la charte des nations
unies actuellement à l'onu c'est la
chine qui préside le conseil de sécurité
un allié de taille pour les autorités
maliennes comme la russie membre
permanent de ce conseil jointe un peu
plus tôt par france 24 la mission
française de l'onu confirme qu'aucune
réunion du conseil de sécurité sur le
mali n'est à l'ordre du jour
en bref sachez qu'une marche prévue ce
mercredi à niamey au niger contre la
présence de soldats de la force marc
khanne dans le pays a été interdite ses
organisateurs ont annoncé avoir décidé
de lancer une pétition exigeant leur
départ
ces nouveaux heurts en guinée après un
appel à manifester contre les militaires
au pouvoir des groupes de jeunes ont
affronté à coups de pierres les
policiers les gendarmes dans la banlieue
de conakry le front national pour la
défense de la constitution avait appelé
à se mobiliser pacifiquement malgré
l'interdiction de toute manifestation
depuis le 13 mai dernier les précisions
de notre correspondant l'amitié quitter
un dispositif sécuritaire très
impressionnant a été déployé tôt ce
matin au point de départ de la
manifestation aucun manifestant n'était
présent sur les lieux dont la matinée
dont les quartiers favorables au front
national pour la défense de la
constitution le mouvement qui a appelé à
manifester un gros dispositif
sécuritaire a été installé des membres
d'élite de l'armée guinéenne ont été
déployés tout au long de lax à cet
endroit la plupart des commerces et
stations services sont restés fermés ce
mercredi les habitants sont restés
terrés chez eux la circulation
habituellement embouteillés est resté
fluide dans quelques quartiers en
banlieue de conakry des accrochages ont
éclaté entre les forces de sécurité et
des jeunes manifestants les forces de
l'ordre ont usé de gaz lacrymogènes pour
rappel depuis le 26 juillet dernier
l'armée a été réquisitionné par les
autorités guinéennes pour je cite
maintenir l'ordre dans le pays le front
national pour la défense de la
constitution a été dissous début ou par
les militaires au pouvoir à qui on
interdit toute manifestation
le mouvement réclame je cite le retour à
l'ordre constitutionnel
la déclaration du président élu au kenya
william route acquis après à la parole
deux jours après avoir été déclaré
vainqueur a promis que son futur
gouvernement répondrait aux énormes
attentes des kenyans et qui la
rendraient des comptes écoutez
nous avons remporté cette élection
contre toute attente
notre gouvernement doit rendre des
comptes nous prendrons les mesures
nécessaires afin de nous assurer que
nous gouvernons de façon transparente
démocratique est redevable
voilà c'était william ruto le président
élu du kenya
sans surprise la constitution
controversée a été adoptée en tunisie la
nouvelle loi fondamentale qui renforcera
nettement les prérogatives du chef de
l'état a été approuvé par un peu plus de
deux millions et demi de personnes cette
nouvelle constitution avait été proposée
par le président queille ça aide auteur
d'un coup de force il y a un an la
correspondance à tunis de lucas bleys
sur le plan politique les résultats
définitifs n'ont pas suscité beaucoup de
réactions notamment parce qu'il était
attendu après le plébiscite en faveur du
oui au projet constitutionnel du
président de la république le 25 juillet
dernier mais sur le plan officiel il
symbolise la proclamation de la nouvelle
constitution et sa mise en vigueur par
le président de la république une
constitution qui consacre un régime
hyper présidentialiste alors beaucoup de
tunisiens attendent de cassayet d' au
tournant avec cette nouvelle
constitution notamment sur les réformes
économiques et sociales que le président
de la république a promis
son gouvernement est actuellement en
train de négocier un prêt de plusieurs
milliards de dollars avec le fonds
monétaire international mais aussi en
train de d'adoucir le ton avec les
partenaires sociaux et le patronat et
puis sur le plan juridique il ya aussi
une fronde en contre caixa est d'une
certaine partie des magistrats les
magistrats qui avaient été révoqués 1
pour motifs de corruption par le
président de la république il ya
quelques mois aujourd'hui 42 d'entre eux
ont été réintégrés dans leurs fonctions
par le tribunal administratif qui a
rejeté le fait qu'ils aient été limogé
mais le ministère de la justice et le
président de la république campent sur
leurs positions
donc c'est plusieurs défis aussi bien
politiques sociaux économiques qui
attendent le président de la république
et son gouvernement pour la rentrée
ces incendies meurtriers en algérie au
moins huit personnes sont mortes et
plusieurs blessés dans des feux de
forêts qui ont touché mercredi 14
départements du nord du pays selon la
radio algérienne la protection civile
fait état de routes coupées de flammes à
proximité de certaines villes c'est le
cas à souk ahras à la frontière
tunisienne où toujours selon les médias
trois cent cinquante personnes ont été
évacuées
le sort de la dépouille de l'ancien
président angolais a été tranchée par la
justice espagnole un tribunal a décidé
et que le corps de josé eduardo dos
santos décédé le mois dernier à
barcelone devait être remis à sa veuve
pour être rapatrié et inhumé en angola
la dépouille de l'ancien chef de l'état
est au centre d'un bras de fer juridique
entre saveurs et l'une de ses filles
un bras de fer dans un contexte
d'élections en angola le 24 août
prochain 14 millions de personnes sont
attendues dans les urnes pour élire leur
président et pour la première fois les
angolais résidant à l'étranger vont
pouvoir voter et peut-être même faire la
différence dans ce scrutin qui s'annonce
très serré entre le président sortant
joão lorenzo et son rival
adalberto pardon costa junior sophie
lamothe
il y environ quatre mille angolais qui
dit blanc de chez eux et pour la
première fois et vont pouvoir voter aux
élections présidentielles
c'est nouveau pour la première fois de
l'histoire un angolais au portugal en
europe qui s'est inscrit peut voter
c'est très émouvant c'est la première
fois de ma vie que je vais voter
deux grands favoris dans une course qui
s'annonce serré le président sortant
zhao lourenço à la tête du mpla le parti
au pouvoir depuis l'indépendance du pays
il a succédé à josé eduardo dos santos
après 40 ans au pouvoir lorenzo a
ensuite lancé à son encontre plusieurs
investigations sur des accusations de
corruption
ce premier rassemblement arrive à un
moment où les citoyens angolais faut
encore le deuil du président josé
eduardo dos santos
mais la vie continue et sa plus grande
joie serait de revoir son mp elle a
gagné ses cinquièmes élections générales
en angola
il se posa à d'alberto costa junior à la
tête du parti d'opposition unita lui
concentré sur la jeunesse angolaise la
croissance économique et le besoin de
renouveau dans la classe politique sa
popularité est montée en flèche de 13%
en 2010 9 à 22 % aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ce rassemblement montre que l'angola ne
renoncera pas à ce droit de défendre son
avenir amené à différents radieux
selon certaines ong de nombreux droits
de l'homme auraient été bafoués pendant
la campagne deux mille angolais et au
moins 50 observateurs internationaux
surveilleront les bureaux de vote et le
dépouillement dans le but de garantir
des élections libres et équitables
on en vient à ce scandale au cameroun
près de 1000 recrues de l'armée
camerounaise viennent d'être radié pour
faux diplômes un phénomène fréquent dans
ce pays où le chômage pousse de nombreux
jeunes a tout tenté pour décrocher un
emploi on fait le point avec notre
correspondant à lyon des marcel amont
coup
ce sont quasiment tous les corps de
l'armée camerounaise qui sont épinglés
dans ce scandale de faux diplômes on y
retrouve notamment huit élèves officiers
de l'école militaire interarmées mais
c'est surtout la gendarmerie qui est la
plus touchée ils sont donc au total près
de 1000 élèves gendarmes sous-officiers
et militaires du rang qui viennent
d'être radié les effectifs des forces de
défense et de sécurité camerounaises la
liste interminable est contenue dans un
message porté signé du ministre délégué
à la présidence de la république chargé
de la défense joseph beti assomo qui
parle d'une politique de tolérance zéro
à la fraude au sein des forces armées
camerounaises elle n'exclut pas des
poursuites judiciaires à l'encontre des
mis en cause le phénomène n'est pas
nouveau ici sur cameron mais c'est son
ampleur et sur tout le corps touchés qui
a choqué l'opinion publique dans un pays
gangrené par la corruption plusieurs
fois classé du no 1 mondial part
transparancy international et ont trouvé
un emploi relève d'une véritable gageure
les jeunes qui vont et semble donc prêt
à tout pour intégrer la fonction
publique
ce drame au sahara occidental une
touriste française a été tuée par une
meute de chiens elle est décédée des
suites de ses blessures à l'hôpital le
phénomène des chiens errants est
également un vrai fléau au maroc le
gouvernement marocain a annoncé vouloir
se donner les moyens pour y faire face
les campagnes d'abattage sont interdites
le roi mohamed 6 a ordonné à
l'instauration d'une loi pour protéger
les animaux d'autres méthodes sont
envisagées pour éradiquer les preuves le
problème voyez ce reportage de notre
correspondant à casablanca jean marie
ils seraient plus de 2 millions de
chiens errants à travers tout le maroc
que ce soit en zone urbaine ou rurale se
sont parfois de véritables meute qui
s'installent dans les rues et à
proximité des habitations
bien qu'assez rares les risques de
morsures et de nuisances sont bien réels
et bon nombre d'habitants font part de
leurs inquiétudes et de leur
exaspération
on se pose beaucoup de problèmes quand
je sors le matin dans la rue j'ai peur
parce que je suis seul et qu'il ya des
siennes qui ont la rage j'ai peur pour
les enfants surtout fait la nuit ils
font tellement de bruit que ça nous
empêche de dormir durant plusieurs
années un système d'abattage était
organisée par les autorités mais cette
solution a rapidement montré son
inefficacité
depuis 2010 9 cette méthode est
interdite mais seuls quelques
associations pour la protection des
animaux financé par bidon aidés par des
bénévoles et quelques vétérinaire tente
de combattre tuque décrivent certains
comme étant véritable fléau nous allons
jamais pouvoir éradiquer les chiens
errants dans le milieu urbain viii à
l'abattage note florian plutôt procéder
à des stérilisations pour minimiser les
porter ça c'est une bonne chose vacciner
les chiens contre la rage parce que ça
c'est un danger potentiel que ce soit
pour l'animal ou pour l'huma à ce
phénomène de l'abandon des animaux
domestiques en grande partie responsable
de cette situation
les associations se mobilisent à travers
tout le royaume ce refuge est ouvert
depuis 2015 ici des milliers de chiens
ont transité mais seulement une centaine
a été stérilisés faute de moyens
financiers plus par an quand reçoit ses
des chiens malades on essaie de les
traiter bien sûr
les autorités en porte de la rage on est
en train de s'entraider et collaborer
avec les autorités pour adopter une
nouvelle méthode éthiques un mâle était
casse bien sûr durable et cette méthode
recommandée par le ms a déjà fait ses
preuves dans d'autres pays dans ce tout
nouveau dispensaire animalier
entièrement financé par l'état au coeur
de la forêt de maâmora ce sont vingt
mille chiens et chats qui devrait y
transiter annuellement dès le début de
l'année prochaine les futurs
pensionnaires ils seront soignés
vacciner déparasiter et une
stérilisation de masse sera réalisé par
des vétérinaires conventionnés il reste
à l'association d'obtenir le budget pour
le bon fonctionnement de ce centre
expérimental dont l'exemple devrait se
développer dans plusieurs régions du
maroc
avant de se quitter cette triste
nouvelle le chanteur rwandais yves
hambourg à vannes est mort à l'âge de 27
ans des suites d'un cancer en inde ii le
recevra des soins de fil annonce son
décès parce famille les hommages sont
nombreux le jeune auteur compositeur
interprète avait déjà sorti trois albums
au premier qui mélangent et afro r'n'b
et pop avait été récompensé récompensé
par le prix découvertes rfi en 2018 et
en lui rend hommage également parce
qu'ils étaient en musique c'est la fin
du journal de l'afrique rester avec nous
l'info continue surprenant
ouais
à
[Musique]